my name is Pat poitras I'm Jim poitras
graduated from MIT in 1963 we have three
daughters one of whom suffers from a
serious mental illness we have a
daughter who's bipolar and even when she
was a youngster 34 years old we knew she
was a little bit different there was
something not quite right so when our
daughter became ill uh I I was clueless
as to what to do who to go to after we
reached a certain level of her care and
treatment we decided that any
philanthropic effort we did any major
focus would would have to do with major
mental illness we were invited Jim and I
to be on the leadership board at the
McGovern the idea that there actually
had a clinical focus of doing basic
research was incredibly appealing to us
we decided we were going to make a
really major gift and really get them
going on it not just talking about it
and and that's fortunately that's what's
happened and it's been amazingly
gratifying the poitras center was set up
at McGovern Institute in order to
facilitate research into a major mental
illnesses this seemed to be the right
place you know we I look at as an
investor we're investing a lot of money
hopefully doing something that's
important I'd love to see another two
three four people step forward and make
an equal commitment this is now
basically three years after the
establishment the center we already see
some research that is coming out for
example John gabrielli found out that
there were definitely differences that
they could identify doing imaging
between a schizophrenic and a control
that's a piece of research that's
happened at the Poitras Center and could
theoretically be ignite diagnostic tool
when Bob DeSimone called us and informed
us that dropping things
coming to MIT and would be the portress
professor of the chair we had
established we were delighted the
support from approach family you
basically your ability to really go
after high risk and high impact research
they have a passion and interest in
particularly interested in bipolar
disorders and the support is basic is
critical for attracting me here I think
not only financial support but also they
are perishing this message of hope there
that that you're not alone there are
others who have this problem and that
our good things are happening I hope
really is what research like this is
giving giving families like ours
you